let's bring out baby Jesus death under
one writer for the opinion section of
the New York Times very license back
with us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
quickly but you did do it everybody
loved you and also you're stood upon my
side about a lot of issues and by this
point of the show I'm so argued out I
gotta have no but I know we're both sort
of fighting the outrage machine you know
the the professional outrage people and
let's just first get out your cuz I saw
you got into some hot water for nothing
I've gotten in a bunch of hot water okay
but the the immigration it's gotten to
the point where like I don't even know
what the [ __ ] they're mad at anymore I
used to at least go okay I get it I
understand it's ridiculous but I get now
I don't even understand what they're mad
at the tweet was what you were watching
the Olympics marina gasps ooh a person
born in California her parents are
Japanese immigrants landed a historic
triple axel at the Olympics I tweeted
out video along with a lyric from
Hamilton that said immigrants they get
the job done now the actual lyric is we
I got the lyric wrong how dare you and I
was jumped upon no here's the thing
anyway
I despise xenophobia anyone who reads my
work yes knows that I love immigrants
and the idea that you know hold on the
idea that I but in any way contribute to
a culture of hostility towards
minorities and immigrants is horrible to
me and I feel awful that anyone heard it
that way what what is what is your
estimation of why there is this fringe
on the left that it tax people like you
and me who they must know are not racist
well is it just lazy that it's just too
hard to attack the real villain I think
that so you you fight battles way behind
enemy lines
I think a it's the narcissism of small
differences anyone that departs from
local orthodoxy gets a lot more heat in
my opinion than people on the actual
right I also think that offense taking
is being weaponized it is a route now to
political power saying that I am
offended is a way of making someone
radioactive it's a way of smearing their
reputation of making them a liability
because once you tar someone as a racist
or a misogynist or a fascist or whatever
the word of the day is you know it's a
way of sort of taking them down a peg
and I'm really concerned
and not about you know people that have
a public platform like me or like you
but the downstream effects of these
smearing x' because here's what happens
if you're someone who wants to get into
the public square and wants to see
something provocative and keep your head
out over the parapet you are not gonna
do that
you are gonna hesitate from doing that
if you know that there's a mob awaiting
you and you see what happens notes are
very very prominent people for for
saying sort of the smallest things yeah
say one more thing I mean you know just
husband ideas I call it I'm just running
off well I really I've been revisiting
the the Philip Roth book the Human Stain
okay the Human Stain
two sentences on it it's about a
classicist at a small liberal arts
school who uses the word spooks meaning
ghosts he means it literally right it's
taken as a racist slur and what happens
to him is personal ruin now the irony of
this is he himself is a light-skinned
black man whose passing is a Jew I'm
reminded of this because we sort of live
in the age of the digital stain what
people are trying to do is to take even
the most well-intentioned an anodyne
comment intentionally torque it and then
throw it out through the echo chamber of
social media in order to ruin people's
reputations and I think it's very
strange that were the most privileged
people in human history objectively and
yet people are spending all of their
time on earth
hurling pixels at one another I thought
it a very very strange use of people's
time well I mean it's so well said all
of it
and I also think people are
schizophrenic they're the real people
who talk in private with their friends
and how they conduct themselves in a
session it's not and then there's like
because everybody's on social media
that's like their avatar and that person
is super politically correct right about
everything it's like everybody has their
own publicist who's them on social media
and also in real life people are
civilized people say I'm sorry I didn't
mean that i understanding but on social
media they're acting like Torquemada
'he's I mean it's bizarre